as kate addressed 20 students 20 have
died by suicide during the pandemic
countless others dealing with mental
health challenges from isolation
disconnection and missing the
interactive school environment with the
younger kids heading back march 1st we
wanted to point out that the ages of the
children who died by suicide were fourth
grade up through high school that is the
exact age range that will continue to
distance learn there is no return date
yet for those students dr jarrah did
touch on the order of students return
we have to make sure that we deliver
pre-k 3
perfect right that we have no issues
there's no spread of the buyers and i
see as we see the numbers going down
when we see the vaccines across this
community and we see the principles are
being able to manage and they're doing a
great job to be able to do that
now if and when the hybrid plan goes
well as it has in private and religious
and even some charter schools across the
valley for months now then ccsd will
start to look at the other older grade
levels
you got to be slow methodically and
strategic to start moving forward we
wanted to make sure we addressed this
because we know many of you with kids in
the fourth grade and higher are asking
what about my child